what's up
guys bang bang lunch money time while
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here i'm wearing
in the uniform i'm wearing my new black
t-shirt is that new
yeah yeah i got it with you remember hey
i got my fancy hoodie on we're ready to
roll
don't forget lunch money's not sponsored
by block five block five has three
products one you can buy and sell crypto
two you can deposit krypton take out a
usd
loan or three three three is you can
earn up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing
account go get a block by account at
block five dot com slash pomp
it is a no brainer go do it block
five.com
what's up hey all right stop texting
your friends about
christmas music we'll get to that later
i was texting my friends about christmas
music come on
what's the first topic so you know how
the u.s
was like hey we got a vaccine for
coronavirus that's 90
effective well russia is now trying to
one-up the u.s
saying that its coronavirus vaccine is
92 percent
effective so which one will you take
y'all gonna take the russian vaccine
it's 92
percent um and i think are you all gonna
take the u.s
vaccine i think putin took it maybe
that might be fake news i don't know no
no no no you don't think so i thought he
did look
you know what's gonna happen they're
gonna come out with a vaccine
there's gonna be multiple ones and
somehow they're gonna underwrite which
ones are safe and which ones are i'm not
a scientist i don't know
am i gonna take the vaccine i don't know
i don't have any information yet how am
i supposed to decide
but what i will tell you is i ain't
taking a russian vaccine
the hell y'all crazy what if i took the
right by the way i got no problem with
russians
wait what if what if i were basically
russian like we're cool
bulgarians and russian when they speak
it sounds the same does it not
no you can't understand russians when
they're speaking russian
she's lying okay she just lied to you
she knows that she can
i i really can't and russians can
understand some bulgarian
very very and then when you when i see
russian written on a wall i'm like oh
look it's bulgarian like no that's
russian it says
and then you translate it for me facts
i'll never lie to you our partner here
on the other side don't ever compare me
with russians again
and two i would take a bulgarian vaccine
okay what if we just have goat cheese in
it
it would actually have good that's
literally they were just like ah just
drink some water and take olive oil some
goat cheese
um what what if i took the russian
vaccine you took the american vaccine
and then we see
what happens to each of us well it's not
like uh i become a spy you know how
well that's the reason why i'm not gonna
take that one
uh all right let's just keep going i
don't want to get too deep into the
conspiracy theories of the vaccine but
i'm still
european central bank president
christine lagarde
cautioned wednesday against an immediate
economic impact
from a vaccine while also giving more
details about what
the central bank is likely to do next
she said
while the latest news on the vaccine
looks encouraging we could still face
recurring cycles of accelerating
viral spread and tightening restrictions
so basically she's saying that
european central bank is hinting at
further monetary stimulus before the
year ends
of course why did they want to print
money so bad
they they basically they took the
economy the economy is like a patient
it's laying in a hospital bed
and they jammed a needle into its arm
and they got the drip and they're just
waiting to squeeze it
and just push more and more stimulus
into their arm as fast as possible
because this is what central banks do
central bankers
all lack one key skill they ain't got no
patience
they ain't got no strong stomachs they
literally
sit there and the second something looks
like it might be going wrong
oh my god pull the lever drop interest
rates they pull the next lever
then they start printing money they
literally can't help themselves
they're interventionist they can't sit
by and just
allow the free market to work they have
to step in they have to do something to
make it feel like
oh we're in control news flash you ain't
in control
you're literally not in control you guys
injected three trillion dollars into the
u.s economy earlier this year
you pumped asset prices to the [ __ ]
moon
and yet the economy didn't recover there
literally is a true k-shape recovery
you made the rich richer and you made
the poor poor so
good job maybe if you guys didn't
actually
intervene and you allowed the free
market to play out what would happen is
the bad companies would go away they
would have to go through bankruptcy
the assets would transfer to better
capital allocators
and people would be put in a position
where they're not dependent on the
government
sending another 1200 check remember the
first 1200
check in the stimulus package uh i think
it was steve mninschen
went on uh television and he said oh
that'll last for 10 weeks
well newsflash it doesn't last for 10
weeks 1200
for an average family and two is they
never sent another one
they just screwed everybody so instead
what ended up happening rather than us
having the hard conversations and doing
the hard things up front
what they did was they stepped in and
they half-assed the intervention
so okay now everyone's suffering
literally san francisco shutting down
restaurants
you can't go inside your restaurant
right now uh in san francisco
they're literally uh putting people in
the new york post i read this morning
that had a wedding that they're calling
a super spreader event
they're like publicly shaming these
people who just wanted to get married
right nobody died some people got sick
but it's like if everyone goes to an
event and all of a sudden everyone gets
the flu
right it's just you got to understand
central banks
stay out of people's lives allow the
free market to work
okay um but they're still going to print
another they're a couple trillion
dollars was coming
they're going injected the needle's
already in we're ready we're already in
the hospital
what are your metaphors because we're
drug addicts oh okay
the economy is a drug addict do you want
to explain that yeah we're addicted to
stimulus
you see what's happening right now
stocks all of a sudden start to stutter
and there's sputter stutter sputter or
whatever it's all the same thing i could
be a rapper
and basically the economy starts to
suffer when they're not
pumping liquidity into the market
mortgage applications
all of a sudden tapering off six of the
last seven weeks u.s mortgage
applications in the united states
have dropped it's still up year over
year 16
in this last week but the reason why
it's dropping
is because there's no fresh liquidity
coming into the market
and also because they dropped interest
rates which is supposed to help people
and incentivize people to borrow money
but when they borrow that money they
went and bought houses
and there was such an imbalance in the
supply and demand that literally house
prices
exploded and now the houses are too
expensive for people
like okay so the central bankers made it
too expensive to buy a home
in america that's literally what
happened the central bankers have made
it
harder to buy a home in america
think about that go ahead mic drop
okay calm down oh i'm good i'm having a
great day i got that
that [ __ ] trillionaire energy today
let's go where'd you get that
i got in a bottle sometimes i just drink
it in the morning
give me some of that maybe i should have
a personal uh central banker
so they can just pump me with money
whenever i need it
all right the u.s and europe's
anti-trust watchdogs
have zeroed in on amazon's treatment of
third-party sellers alleging the company
engages in anti-competitive conduct
both probes highlight risks around
amazon's usage of third-party seller
data
and its control of the buy box
anti-trust experts say that amazon may
face
harsher penalties in the eu europe
where regulators have taken a more
aggressive stance on big tech companies
yeah just gonna say something the market
loves winners
governments hate winners that's all this
is
they're too good at their job that's
basically what people are saying
if you don't want to sell against amazon
don't put your [ __ ] on amazon
it's not that hard go put it somewhere
else no but the point is that it's
antitrust no they're saying that amazon
is using
data from their platform to then go
build their own products to compete with
people
do you remember what happened with atoms
but but
again it's a free market what's the
difference between that and somebody in
china being like hmm
those uh those speakers are really
popular we're gonna make our own the
difference is that
bezos is not in china he's a us-based
company okay there's u.s companies all
the time
how how come all of a sudden but they
are so large
they will crush you like it's not like
some dude in his garage
but but that's not true that's my point
is they'll crush you until something new
and better comes along if you go to my
youtube page
paulino marinova i think that's what it
is um you will find
a video that i did with squares founder
where he talks about how amazon tried to
crush them
but they couldn't it's a good one okay
exactly my point
we talk about that because it's so rare
that's that's the exception not the rule
no it's not amazon has failed over and
over and over again trying to do that
let's agree to disagree chipotle
open its first digital only restaurant
is
online orders soar i wrote about this
this morning oh did you
yeah but you don't know because you
don't read what i write because i was
sleeping she was she's up till 10 a.m
okay
until 10 o'clock in the morning i
couldn't fall asleep until like
two so i technically only got eight
hours
guys she slept till 10 a.m it she
couldn't fall asleep because i checked
the watch
how many hours did you sleep um last
night he got mad at me because i like
i i wasn't sleeping and he was sleeping
and i just pushed him
to his side because he keeps like coming
over to my side he was like
what are you doing just let me sleep and
i was like you've been sleeping
two hours i gotta sleep in full combat
gear literally i'm sleeping and i'm just
getting beat up and like pushed and
shoved and [ __ ] i'm like hey i'm trying
to sleep
all right all right chipotle they're
gonna create restaurants that basically
there's no
dining and there's no place to walk in
and order so there's no like cashiers or
anything you basically can order on the
mobile app you can order on the website
or you can order through a third-party
delivery service
and you can get the food one of two ways
either they'll deliver it to you
shocking delivery orders or you can go
and basically like do curbside pickup
type things right so you pre-ordered it
and then when you get there you just
grab it and leave
okay that sounds like a recipe for theft
you think people okay if you just lay
out everybody's orders out there
somebody's gonna go
in and take like five no why not
they do it right now if you go to cava
right now they're all just sitting there
and people
look through it and get theirs
i come from bulgaria that would not fly
in bulgaria let me just tell you that
okay okay all right no problem
alphabet this is a really cool story
guys alphabet will soon deliver
wireless internet over light beams in
kenya
using a technology that can cover
distances of up to
20 kilometers it's called project tara
and it's conducted a series of pilots in
kenya last year
and is now partnering with a telecom
company to deliver internet access in
remote parts of africa so basically what
it does it has
it doesn't have cables and not fiber but
it shoots
light beams that shoot internet
they shoot light beams that shoot the
internet uses light to transmit data but
without the cables that's similar to
fiber optic
but it's a laser it's so cool it's above
ground rather than below ground yeah
and you can just shoot because light
travels
i'm not gonna comment on our uh
our infrastructure expert that we uh
brought it's like cnbc when they bring
somebody on
and that that person just says like very
uh obvious things like the market went
up today
i do not say obvious things i say light
is cool well you just said light travels
yeah that's travel why wouldn't they use
sound
then because light travels faster than
sound okay
um last topic is my favorite topic
here's my deal i'm a big fan of
christmas i love
christmas i'm cool with christmas me and
christmas we get along great santa's fat
ass comes down the chimney
we are chilling we are good the cookies
in milk
the surprise like we're cool but you
know what i'm not cool with
what playing christmas music before
thanksgiving it should be
it should be a crime you should be put
in jail if you do that and starbucks
today i walked into starbucks while you
were sleeping
and they were playing it they were
literally playing christmas music
like santa's fat ass is going to pop
down the chimney tomorrow
it is thanksgiving hasn't happened okay
in 2020 we need a little bit more
holiday
joy than normal years and
i will say oh maybe i should they were
playing the sad christmas songs too
oh i don't like like the slow ones like
if you're gonna play the the
popping ones the ones with random ears
and stuff i'm gonna i have a little baby
christmas tree no we don't need them
no we do what are the questions wait
hold on but i love christmas
because and first of all how do you how
are you gonna say that when i was
literally cooking the other day and
there's christmas music playing you
didn't say a word
do you guys see how tolerant i am
that was a perfect example how tolerant
i am all right let me first
question my tolerance goes unappreciated
in my house
hold ready um ask lunch money hashtag
ask
lm put it in the comments we'll answer
your question oh yeah send us questions
so i have other things to talk about
rather than just rant about [ __ ] go
ahead
uh bro kid show kids brent kt woohoo
um what would you tell someone looking
for ways to improve their positive
outlook on life
i have my own views but i'm really
interested in the remedies for stress
anxiety mental health etc
you seem to be too very common positive
individuals
him much more so than me obviously i
understand the lunch money and palm
podcast aren't 100 percent
representation of your lives
so you answer first oh so i've been
doing a lot of
yoga and meditation but sometimes
there's people and situations that get
to me
and then you know i have to do more yoga
and meditation
so i'm not the best person to ask about
this because i feel like i'm much
i have much more anxiety than our friend
here who literally
i i don't i can't remember last time you
worried about something he doesn't get
the concept of worry like i do
i worry what are you worried about
ruminate i'm like oh my god what's gonna
happen
what do you how do you handle it we're
all gonna die like you listening right
now you're gonna die
i promise i promise you're gonna die
there's gonna be a day
where your eyes so how do you make life
more enjoyable
knowing that it's just you just got time
it's running out
go [ __ ] live your life it's it's real
simple live your life
that is literally it what are you
worried about you worried about that
uh the shoes you want to buy at the
store on sale who cares
you worry that your friend's talking
[ __ ] who cares all right wait
none of that stuff matters you're gonna
die a hypothetical let's say sure
let's say you you know are a single
parent with a kid and the pandemic is
happening and suddenly like you can't
get enough like you're just worried
about really big things in your mind
that could affect the future of your
family how do you deal with something
like that
worrying doesn't help like that's the
whole thing is
that's why i always talk about personal
responsibility
and like your individual rights right is
okay cool if you're a single parent and
you've got a young kid and you're
worried about money stop [ __ ]
worrying and go figure out how to make
more money
like and that sounds ruthless i get it
people are like oh my god i can't
believe you say that
but at the end of the day the worrying
is not going to solve the problem the
thing that's going to solve the problem
is action
and what you'll find is that when you
start to act you stop worrying that's
true
like that's it so cool if you're in a
bad situation right now
acknowledge i'm in a bad situation this
sucks i need to fix it
and the only way that you're gonna fix
it is if you do something i have one
more recommendation go ahead
um if you look up a man named
noah galloway um i recently listened to
his podcast that he did with tom bilyeu
in which he talks about mental health
anxiety and depression
and he went to iraq and he was blown
up and lost his arm and his leg and he
came back and fell into a really
deep depression because he was like
suddenly i'm a wounded veteran by the
way today is veterans day thank you
um he went to iraq okay uh so
so he came back and he was um dealing
with a lot
and then he said he realized one day
that his depre
basically when he would feel depressed
it was that he was
stuck in an old chapter of his life he
kept replaying the same thing over and
over and over again
and he's like hold on a second it's been
five years since i was
in that place in that mental state why
am i still there
so his point is you have to be able to
move on to a new chapter of your life
whether that means um
so he decided for him it was fitness he
felt
so insecure about only having an arm one
arm and one leg
he decided to go to the gym at 2 a.m
when nobody could see him so he could
work out get into shape
go run marathons go do tough mudders and
show
like you know people with four
limbs do this i can do it with two like
it builds self-confidence so i think
finding ways to build self-confidence
and trying to write the next chapters of
your life
helps you move on worrying is a mental
exercise and you're in control of your
mental state
sure by the way if you really want to
just stop worrying go listen to jay-z
big pimpin
all-time
and next question from melvin milari uh
bang bang how do you get past the cold
start problem of building an audience
when you don't have one
do you just consistently produce content
or do you do something else to
bootstrap the growth you go no you
answer first why do you always make me
do this
i think um so i so when i
when i left my job and i started doing
the profile full time i didn't have that
big of an audience
and when i talked to him we talked about
how you have to punch above your weight
you have to be able to create something
even if you're small
where when people turn there's the
profile here they turn this way the
profile's here you have to create
inflection points that build momentum
on each other and make you look like
you're
everywhere all over the internet all
over twitter all over linkedin
instead of just creating more content
that nobody will read you won't be able
to read your stuff
so you have to create literally what i
did was created a plan
monday i will like
promote this article here i will ask
these people to retweet it i will do
whatever
just just to keep the momentum going
the other thing is uh when you're trying
to bootstrap something
everyone always thinks of it as a single
player exercise
right so it's always like oh how do i
create content and then i distribute
that content and then i get the audience
to show up
but what you start to realize is the
people who are the best at building
audiences
look at it as a multi-player exercise
and what i mean by that
is cool i have a email that i want to
grow
i could sit and i could write all day
and then just tweet it to my six
followers
right or what i could do is i can go
convince somebody with a big following
to let me interview them
get it in a written format put it in the
email then i tweet it out then i dm it
to them then they retweet it
right that helps me get followers it
helps me get people to the email like
little hacks like that i think are
really important or even better instead
of you
interviewing them have them write a
guest post yeah you could do that
and at the end of the day though you
just got to grind
like people look at the audiences that
we've built and things like we've been
doing this a long time
years years this wasn't like oh we just
woke up one day and like bam there's
audience right
i mean i've literally been creating
content on the internet in a
intentional way for 17 18 19 almost four
years now
and i started in 2010 and i
anyway that's besides the point that's
taking it away that's getting away from
them
we can't see you from all the way up
here right so low
my brother joe this is what i do my
brother joe got on a
high speed motorcycle you've been on uh
on a horse the whole time
right by anyway yeah
use borrow other people's audiences try
to get out of your own network
facts possible facts all right that's it
cancel christmas music later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends